[Music]
beautiful vine tomatoes the riper the
tomatoes the better the soup take the
core out get you firm and place it half
a centimeter underneath the tip of your
knife place it in and then just twist
around that's the only part of the
tomato that we're not using red onion
and garlic red onion because it's
sweeter than a white onion slice your
onions and your garlic nice and fine
traditionally we make it in a pot it's
so much better to start it off on top of
the stove searing the tomatoes and the
garlic but it goes in the oven you
actually roast those martyrs and they
don't stupid it's a big difference in
flavor be quite generous with the olive
oil
it makes the soup nice and saucy shiny
salt pepper and then a little teaspoon
of cayenne just gives it that heat but
it's not as fierce as chili take your
tomatoes just slice them in half and
then a little touch of sugar that's
going to help intensify the sweetness a
little sprinkle of aged balsamic vinegar
gives that nice dark rich acidity to the
soup
it's the oven 2025 minutes 180 to make
my soup even more irresistible I'm gonna
make a punchy sun-dried tomato pesto to
drizzle over the top now I'm making this
in a pestle and mortar because you feel
so much more in control and you're not
depending on a blade that's whizzing
around a thousand miles an hour next in
a dry pan toast off some pine nuts toast
of the absolute Matt and then in
smelling there is incredible
parmesan idly great there this is where
it starts to become creamy extra virgin
olive oil doesn't need salt because the
parmesan is gonna season it for you and
just take a couple of tablespoons of the
oil the sun-dried tomatoes are in really
helps to make that stunning pesto I can
smell those roasted tomatoes on them out
Wow
next pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes put your spoon through those
tomatoes they break up instantly bring
it out to the ball let it simmer for 3
or 4 minutes want to make a little more
creamy now cream in give that a little
stir you can keep it rustic and yet your
mash are in and you've got that nice
thick rich chunky tomato soup or do
yourself a stick blender
[Music]
blitzing like that you deglaze the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom mmm
that's delicious
to make my lunch extra hearty I'm gonna
knock up a deliciously gutsy version of
cheese on toast to go with my tomato
soup wash rabbit now so classic
we'll make a roux 50 grams of butter
three nice tablespoons of flour that's
all a roux is basically traditionally
you would use flour butter and milk but
in Welsh rabbit the milk is often cheeky
substituted for a stiff slug of stout
gives it that strong gutsy flavor
on it nice thick make sure those lumps
are out there nice teaspoon of Dijon
mustard and then season it nice and
spicy we moist is your source gives it
that delicious intrigue and playable now
that smells amazing almost brings tears
to your eyes
beautiful now Welsh rabbit wouldn't be a
stunning Welsh rabbit without rich
mature cheese so and a great Montgomery
cheddar goes well with beer and top that
in really important to put this in or
the roof still nice and hot because the
cheese melts now for the bread I prefer
good rustic country loaf that will stand
up to my hardcore topping want that nice
crisp base to my wife forever so toast
it both sides
spread that beautiful cheesy berry spicy
mixture just great blister and bubble
and gratinéed got a little splash
leaning in Perry and back under the
grill for 90 seconds in one delicious
creamy roasted tomato soup it's coming
back to me all those days I had off
school poster purposely lie about
feeling ill just to get a bowl of my
mother's tomato soup how bad was that
but my god it was worth it
well now I'll watch forever yeah look at
those babies I just takes cheese on
toast to another level
Wow roasted creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto served with the
most amazing delicious Welsh rabbit I
feel like we in sick
[Music]
start by seizing the meat well
brisket is a cut of beef from the
breasts it's inexpensive but it's fit
for royalty with long slow cooking place
it into hot casserole dish with a little
olive oil and brown on all sides
next make a tasty broth to flavor the
meat into the dish add chopped carrots
celery a whole bulb of garlic cut in
half peppercorns aromatic close and
freshly ground nutmeg
pour in hot water to braise the brisket
[Music]
bring to the boil and cover tightly then
transfer the dish to a low oven and cook
for three to four hours
cook blow and slow the results are
amazing
tender melt in the mouth meat fantastic
with roast potatoes or in sandwiches
with lots of mustard but I like it best
with tangy piccalilli in the oven in
under 10 minutes then all you have to do
is sit back and wait so easy and
absolutely delicious what's not to love
about my succulent beef brisket
first off spices this is a fresh vanilla
pot fragrant and packed full of flavor
you the back of the knife and flatten it
that removes all those little seeds off
the skin of the vanilla pod take your
knife slice down the middle and then
when you open that up smell is
incredible take the tip of the knife and
you scrape inside and look all those
seeds dying to come out that is
incredible there are thousands of seeds
still ingrained to the pod so put them
in to the casserole cardamom powerful
spicy take two little pods place your
knife on top lightly crack them cracking
the cardamom pods helps release all the
amazing flavor clothes because that kind
of aniseed flavor with a lot of depth
one two three cinnamon stick snap and in
just smelling that level of fragrance
you can imagine what the rice put in the
taste-off turn on the heat
lightly toast those spices just a couple
of seconds I was gonna happen it's just
gonna sort of enhance those spices in a
way that it just draws out and even more
powerful fragrance coconut milk in sugar
two tablespoons
milk and then I cover tablespoons of
cream bring it slowly to the boil to
allow the flavors to infuse and this
rice pudding reminds me of my time in
India where I got really into that chai
tea fragrance because it was just so
delicious and so comforting take a lime
in the line just cuts through the
richness of the coconut it gives it that
nice little bit of acidity goes
fantastically well with a cinnamon and
that fresh vanilla nice have a taste
hmm now let's come up to the ball give
it a nice little clean around the
outside and in with the rice use 200
grams of pudding rice don't wash it
beforehand because the starch helps
thicken the rice pudding in the oven and
just turn that down to a light simmer
and the pudding rice starts to open up
and it absorbs all that coconut vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the ball gently and cook it out three to
five minutes balling it rapidly the rice
opens up and it goes into mush I want to
keep that nice texture that sort of
fragrant rice pudding on a gentle simmer
next a little luxury I will show you how
I take this simple delicious aromatic
rice pudding to a completely different
level here's what I do take 2 egg yolks
separate now give that a really nice
whisk
- nice tablespoons of mascarpone cheese
whisk that into the egg yolks just as
nice and smooth it's almost like
finishing the rice pudding and the
delicious custard turn off the gas add
that into the rice pudding and what
happens it starts to enrich and really
thicken this rice pudding and takes it
to a completely different level the rice
is still not cooked start to get a nice
and soft you can just see how it's
opening up but look it's like rich
aromatic lava bubbling away finally
great more citrus zest the lime on top
roasted caramelized lime zest on top of
the rice pudding is phenomenal then put
it in the other 15 minutes at 200
degrees to finish cooking the rice and
develop the intensive aromatic flavors
[Music]
look at that an incredibly fragrant rice
pudding how beautiful is that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive I'll guarantee
you'll never ever have had a rice
pudding like this before
[ __ ] with five a great British classic
absolutely delicious mint vegetables
potatoes easy
Olive Oyl
minced lamb still the color on the mince
and it gets rid of that unwanted fat
nothing worse than a greasy shepherd's
pie season
great onion
garlic once the vegetables are grated in
there they could simply great and almost
puree adding great flavor and that's the
secret behind a really good shepherd spy
it's all in the mince what's the sauce
tomato puree
red wine
thyme rosemary right now the red wines
evaporated chicken stock in and cook it
out for three or four minutes no more
than that
potatoes mash season
egg yolks now
secret ingredient Parmesan cheese
be quite generous for the parmesan
because that's what gets it really nice
and golden brown now deserve to sit on
top of my mints
[Applause]
good old-fashioned tip just give mama
happy
the top 18 to 20 minutes in the oven
the crispy topping you can see what that
deserves to be a great British classic
shepherd's pie done first off I'm gonna
make a really nice light Carol pan on
nice and low great to apples and this
helps to almost sort of purely apples so
much quicker as a lot of flavoring the
skin so don't worry about peeling the
fruit whether it's pears plums peaches
flavors in the skin nice start the
camera a couple of tablespoons of sugar
the sugar helps to get rid of a tartness
in the apple a touch of cinnamon that
starts to make it a little spicy
open up your vanilla just scrape out all
those seeds now this just makes it light
and fragrant all the seeds in to the
sugar we're making caramel be patient
and always swirl the dish instead of
staring it when the sugar goes Brown add
the apple
[Music]
that starts to sort of cool down the
camel but it gives it a really nice sort
of caramelized pureed apples almost
disintegrating smells incredible 10 I
guess down slice up two apples
it's a crumble that's got no frills
straightforward and faffing around and
peeling of the skin I want them to sort
of stand out from the camera apples in
now there's nice thick chunks of Apple
sort of always bending itself into the
puree dried cranberries gives it that
nice sort of shock in the texture sweet
and chewy I want it to sort of taste
zesty spicy so set the lemon zest on top
of your apples and cranberry fresh lemon
juice over and that just gives that
extra acidic kick takes the cranberries
the apples the camel and the cinnamon to
another level turn the gas off so that's
it let's concentrate on the crumble
flour in I cut the tablespoons of
Demerara sugar sugar helps to get the
topping nice and crispy butter in give
that a nice little filling rub looking
for is like a breadcrumb mixture lightly
seasoned it with a touch of cinnamon and
the Demerara sugar sort of helps to get
a nice fine crumble mix and it stops the
butter I'm sort of melting in that flour
so that's the basic crumble mix but I'm
not finished yet
music two-thirds crumble one third music
mix that in if you haven't got musi then
crunchy granola works brilliantly too
lovely now start off in the center and
work your way around
I want the crispiness on the top the
puree on the bottom of the camel and
then the texture in the center a good
tip
turn the gas back on want it bubbling
before it goes in the oven because then
you just got to cook the top so soon as
you see that camera start to bubble down
the side and she goes let's go bake at
200 degrees Celsius for 12 to 14 minutes
until golden brown smells amazing
[Music]
beautiful still bubbling and look at it
a delicious but very simple crumble with
apples at the absolute best beautiful
you